we have been talking about the debt and
deficit in politics for a very long time
and there's a few different layers of
the discussion on debt and deficit first
of all there is which party is more
responsible for raising the deficit and
which party is more responsible
historically for lowering the deficit
that's one question not what I want to
talk about today there's another
question which is well does the deficit
matter and if so is every deficit dollar
created equal what I mean by that is if
we increase our deficit to pay for
people's health care does that have the
same economic impact as if we increase
our deficit to give really rich people
tax cuts which mostly they put into
their bank accounts that's another
discussion it's not what I want to talk
about with you today now whatever your
view is on the importance of the debt
and deficit on which party tends to
increase or decrease the debt or deficit
there's no denying two realities about
our current president number one Donald
Trump said that he would start paying
off the debt by generating a surplus and
number two Donald Trump has actually
made this problem way worse the debt has
exploded under Donald Trump and we now
have a new report about the fact that
aides who believe the debt as a problem
have been going to trump and saying hey
we kind of need to deal with this Donald
and Donald Trump is shrugging it off
saying he won't be president anymore
when it becomes completely untenable The
Daily Beast has a detailed report about
this and it points out that people show
up at Trump's office and they bring
charts and they bring graphs and
pictures and reports and Trump is saying
yeah but I won't be here when that's a
problem so this is not a political
debate story this is not a debate over
the merits of debt and deficit or over
which party does X Y or Z would that our
deficit this is about the fact that you
have a president that doesn't care about
the country Trump's view and Trump's
view the view of the people around Trump
is the debt is a huge problem I might
disagree you might disagree but if they
believe it and Trump is
saying I don't care I'll blow up the
debt because it's going to be the next
president's problem it's irresponsible
and it's an attack on Americans
Republicans say that the debt and
deficit are a problem for the average
middle-class American if you believe
that it's a direct attack on those
people two uncaring ly blow up the debt
and say ah I don't worry because it's
gonna be the next person's problem it is
anti-american in the sense that it goes
against the interests of Americans
Republicans are becoming way more brazen
in admitting that they're playing
politics pat we talked yesterday about
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham who
admitted hey if Mike Pompeo and Jim
mattis were Democrats I'd say they were
in the pocket of Saudi Arabia because
they're denying that the Saudi Crown
Prince was involved in the killing of
Jamal kajouji but they're Republicans so
I'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt this is a sickness but it is a
sickness that will hurt you or most of
most of you anyway and what's most
stunning about it Pat is they are
becoming brazen and also how does Trump
know that this won't be his problem like
assuming you buy into this idea that the
debt is going to ultimately become so
large that it's going to be untenable
and maybe crash the world's economy how
does how does he know that it's gonna be
the next president's problem like Trump
could be president for the next six
years and we very well could have a debt
crisis under his tenure well I think
that he's being told that it's going to
be the cumulative ly exponentially
increasing interest on the debt beyond
six years that's going to cause the
problem and he just doesn't care he just
says I just don't care about that and
meanwhile what's amazing about this is
that on so Trump's blowing up the
deficit and saying he doesn't care
because he'll be gone before it really
becomes a problem according to the
people that are telling him that
simultaneously Republicans as I've told
you are laying the groundwork to justify
cutting your Social Security and
Medicare because the debt has exploded
and this is sort of like the Republican
view on lots of issues the debt I won't
be here when it explodes climate change
if it's real will be gone let's enjoy
cheap gas and drive SUVs in
structure spending now I won't be
driving anymore when the bridges and
tunnels collapse I'll be retired and
living in Arizona or somewhat what moral
leadership right screw you
I'll be 85 years old and out of office
when it implodes and if you are at
rumpus and you hear this and you defend
it let me know what mental gymnastics
you're using to make it happen because
it's disgusting I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program sponsored in
part by blinkers comm slash Pakman I've
talked about blinkers before it's this
awesome app that I've been using for
several months now and what it does is
take the best and most critically
acclaimed non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from a book in one sitting
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube
click the link in the video description
and after that free trial if you like
blinka stand I think you are going to
like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n